j'ai déjà vécu beaucoup de choses dans
ma vie des épreuves mais aussi de grands
bonheur je suis le vilain petit canard
de ma famille il dirait tout ce que
c'est un délire de petit blanc
privilégié à la
[Musique]
philosophie de vie c'est on s'en bat les
couilles
bonsoir
au début
[Applaudissements]
j'ai grillé un feu et donc quand le
policier m'a arrêté j'ai profité de de
ma différence en fait d'être daltonienne
donc je lui ai dit je suis désolé je
suis daltonienne j'ai pas vu et là il
m'a tout simplement répondu c'est quand
daltony vous n'avez pas de feu tricolore
voilà est-ce que vous lisiez les
mémoires du général de Gaulle aux
toilettes de ce zapping mais
malheureusement suite à la
démonétisation de notre chaîne zap télé
officiel cet été il nous est désormais
impossible de continuer à diffuser les
apps sur Youtube notre appel ayant été
rejeté
mais rassurez-vous deux possibilités
s'offrent désormais à vous pour
continuer de voir les impacts les apes
télé et les apnettes sur vos appareils
connectés première possibilité vous
rendre sur le site zeptele.fr zap
tele.fr pour ceux qui auraient un peu de
mal à taper l'adresse du site dans leur
navigateur on vous a ajouté un lien
direct dans la description juste en
dessous
comme d'habitude vous y trouverez chaque
jour dès 7h du matin le Zap actu 2 apps
télé entre midi et 13h et le Zap net à
18h deuxième possibilité nous vous
proposons de concevoir vous même vos
propres zapping et pour cela et parce
qu'on est sympa chez zap télé on va vous
montrer comment procéder tout d'abord il
vous faut une télévision qui doit rester
allumé en permanence le but étant de ne
rien rater de ce qui se passe dans le
petit écran ensuite vous prenez vos cinq
ordinateurs et vous les programmez pour
enregistrer un maximum de chaînes une
fois vos 250 heures de programme
enregistrées regardez-les
[Musique]
lorsque vous repérez une séquence digne
d'être diffusée dans votre zapping
exportez-la et nommez-la avec un titre
unique et explicite
réitérer cette opération tout au long de
votre visionnage autant de fois qu'il le
faudra
une fois les 250 heures de programmes
des rochers c'est comme ça qu'on dit
dans le jargon allumez votre logiciel de
montage et rangez vos séquences dans
l'ordre qui vous semble le plus
approprié rajoutez les mentions légales
titre production et logo et lancez
l'export de votre vidéo voilà votre
zapping est prêt à être diffusé sur
Internet il ne vous reste plus qu'à vous
connecter à votre chaîne Youtube postez
votre vidéo vous rendre compte qu'il y a
un problème de droit d'auteur retirez
l'extrait problématique de la timeline
sur votre logiciel de montage réexporter
votre zapping puis reposez-le sur
Youtube et voilà votre zapping est en
ligne prêt à être regardé par le plus
grand nombre et être commenté sans
concession par des internautes plus ou
moins à l'aise avec la grammaire sinon
je le rappelle vous avez toujours la
possibilité de vous rendre sur le site
zap télé.fr c'est gratuit et il semble
que les premiers visiteurs soient déjà
totalement satisfaits j'ai halluciné
alors à tout de suite j'espère sur cette
télé point fr gros bisous